for sri lankans panicking to purchase
petrol it may seem like they're watching
their economy crash in slow motion the
government is in debt to a number of
countries including china japan and
india
inflation is soaring and sri lanka's
foreign reserves have dropped now it's
struggling to pay for fuel and this week
announced country-wide blackouts to ease
pressure on the electric grid
happy department we are getting hit from
two sides there's a lack of hydropower
and oil prices are going up that's why
the petroleum sector and the electricity
sector are under tremendous pressure
for several months now some shelves and
shops have been empty and basic goods
like milk are being rationed
the pandemic hit the livelihoods of
thousands of sri lankans working in the
tourism industry
the country is so strapped for cash the
government plans to repay four years of
oil debt to iran with tea
not only fuel people don't have enough
to eat whatever fuel we can get how long
will it last people must understand who
is responsible for these issues they
must understand that and at least at the
next opportunity at elections they must
use their brains to pick the right
politician for the job
in january the government announced a
1.2 billion dollar economic relief
package that will offer help to
government employees farmers and
retirees there's also talk of an
international monetary fund bailout
what's happening now is reminiscent of
the economic crisis in the 1970s
and those who experience that wonder if
it could get even worse
natasha named al jazeera